Let’s look now at what we call the edge
problem. If I try and compute the pixel value
at this particular coordinate the window of
pixels in the input image has to look like
this. And the problem is that some of the
input window has fallen off the edge of the
image. So there are pixel values that are
undefined: the window requires pixel values
that do not exist in the input image. There’s
a couple of solutions to this: one solution
is we simply don’t compute the output value
whenever the window falls off the edge. That
would be all the pixels that are indicated,
hashed out in the right-hand image. We just
wouldn’t be able to compute those.
Another option is to assume that the image
is surrounded by pixels that are all set to
zero. If we put a layer of zero pixels all
around the edge of the image then we can determine
a valid window and from the valid window we
can compute our function. The problem is that
the zeros are somewhat artificial and they
will, of course, influence the result returned
by the function. Another technique is to replicate
the edge pixels. Make copies of those pixels
around the edge; stack them around the image
so that we always have valid pixel values
going into the window.
All of these options have different advantages
and disadvantages; just be aware of the problem
when you are performing spatial operations
on images and in some environments there may
be options you can pass into the software
to tell it how to handle this boundary condition.
We can see the effect of the window falling
off the edge of the input image as a dark
border around the edge of our output image.
Let’s have a look at this image we computed
a short time ago. If we zoom in on the edge
here, we can see quite a rapid drop off in
grey level as we approach the edge of the
image, and this is due to the neighbourhood
window falling off the edge of the input image.
Another thing to be aware of is that the window
size is always odd—it is a square window
and the width and the height are always odd
numbers. The reason for this is the following:
the window is square and it is always centred
on the input pixel. Let’s say that the edge
most pixel is H pixels away from the centre.
In this particular case, H would be equal
to 2. Move from the middle pixel, we step
two pixels to the right and we are at a pixel
which is on the edge of the window. So that
means, then, that the window width is 2H +
1. H is an integer; 2H + 1 is always an odd number.